what is the likelihood that revive and
restore will be allowed to release a
significant population of passenger
pigeons into the wild and what is the
legality of this so this is a question
we have been looking into since we
started this work and what can be
definitively said right now is that
there is no regulatory policy that
absolutely prohibits us from doing so
but there's no regulatory policy that
absolutely allows us to so so some
reworking of policy is necessary and
that's where it comes down to our
supporters the only way we're really
going to advocate and get strong support
for these projects in the regulatory
framework is if the public comes out and
says they want this to happen
public opinion shapes how the US Fish
and Wildlife Service operates 100% more
so than the scientists involved I can
tell you that if people are gonna eat
them someday it'll be regulated by the
FDA yes yes it will be
now the there's a transgenic American
chestnut right now that's going through
the regulatory process that will be the
world's first genetically modified
organism that could be approved for wild
release and so we view this is a very
very fruitful time to be thinking about
these projects and helping to go through
and think about beyond a plant how do
you regulate an animal now revive and
restores black-footed ferret project it
stands to be the first project to
engineer the cells of an endangered
mammal in the world and we're doing this
under the auspices of permissions
permissions in certain ways from the
program and US Fish and Wildlife Service
so we view these as projects that will
help build the regulatory framework and
even though regulation seems to go
slowly
I think there's high likelihood that
when we have enough birds to put in the
wild we will be allowed to put these
birds in the wild but that that depends
on public support
[Music]